where what is the state of play for
Enterprises at that point so where are
they what is their state of data how
prepared are they for what's coming for
generative AI it's it's amazing question
because it was such a happy moment for
me I actually thought it would come
earlier than November 22 it's because
Genera models were um rapidly evolving
since 2017 so 22 was was a big a big
bang for the industry and to me as a
technology person is the biggest thing
about that is it's the first technology
forever since internet probably that CEO
is coming to data people and asking for
this thingy I want that tomorrow right
so it didn't happen with cloud or big
data or neural Nets technology people
were always selling technology to to the
business site so this is the first time
it actually came the other way around so
CE so Chief marketing officer were
coming to to that data Department saying
like I want this chat agentic analytics
whatever I have we have like lots of
buzs around that I want this experience
this Vibe for me tomorrow right I want
to change so the the the expectation yes
expectation was high right and data
people of course their knees were
shaking just you know all of us know how
data looks like in Enterprise and this
is why it's it's manually catered and
delivered within bi tools right
[Music]
Ina thank you for being here Mike thank
you for inviting to me to this it's kind
of a Deja I would say I have never been
to a historic cense but being back to to
the crime scene so to say it's it's
interesting to be in this location yeah
yes we're we're actually in the place
where sense began I believe
hon and humbled amazing H well you I'm
really I'm really excited to to have you
here and to talk about you know
everything that that you're doing and
with h with your company but also a
little bit going backwards to your
journey you've been at the Forefront of
data and Ai and Enterprise and this
intersection for quite some time all the
way from sap obviously cens and today
with your own startup so you've seen the
the world changing but being really at
the at the Forefront of it and so you
know let's just go back to the beginning
for a second tell me a little bit about
how you got into data and also into AI
well such a great
question so young just finished my first
degree in physics in computer science
and it was like yeah so the world is
full of possibilities and it's natural
for for you to want to try everything so
I thought it would be exciting to join
shy gasi organizations at sap back then
to to change the world right change the
world of Enterprise yeah so what we did
we actually invented this application a
development automation before it was a
fashion before Google invented it again
so to say but for Enterprise for it was
fun and so that was was that your first
real experience diving into Enterprise
systems and and this whole world yeah
yeah I did start my career at a Converse
in my Ramadan so this is like kind of M
do and Converse where the major
Enterprise Hightech companies in Israel
for quite a while and just it proved
that Israel can scale and can build
companies not just startups and so I
started in Commerce and it was quite a
journey you know as delivery engineer
what we call right now devops and
especially T called traveling the war to
know the most exotic locations and
delivering this first wave of iPhone
installation for example in Europe so I
got to hold iPhone 2006 like one of the
first one I'm like how many applications
does it have it has a screen leaking cat
right so it was it was pretty amazing
start yeah tell me a little bit about
your experience as a technologist coming
into the world of Enterprise and
Enterprise systems what was that
experience like for you I felt there is
Big disconnect about how technical
people um perceive organizational
systems you know being delivery engineer
in Commerce and installing this billing
systems and connecting them to
operational system of Telco companies
and then at sap where basically what
happened is um we installed this huge
operational Financial Erp systems right
for companies like Walmart Pacific
Builder and so on and then you bring
this automation about how you develop
interfaces but then you talk to business
people and they perceive their data in
totally different way and Technical
people do so it was evident to me back
then that there is Big disconnect about
how data is managed and about how data
is used and I don't think it changed a
lot since then so let Let's uh help me
understand the two aspects so data is
managed data is used what what do the
what do each of these mean so let's take
sense for example business intelligence
company people when they use dashboards
and I love dashboards you know I open my
morning with my Pipeline and everything
looks great and or not great but you
know this is something to fix being able
to to basically comprehend your data on
the daily basis is is just a you know
prerequisite phone for making
intelligent decision making the thing is
usually dashboards are static and not
flexible enough for for experience so
for example if you do have more
questions business questions you have to
go to analyst and ask them to model new
data right for you to be able to to ask
a question and that usually takes
between two weeks and two months really
depends on your seniority and complexity
of the underlying data and right now in
this wave of Genera VII where everyone
knows what GPT is capable of and like
why wouldn't I plug GPT to my database
and start asking questions and
unfortunately it's not as simple and it
was evident to me you know back then
when I decided to start ILX to to solve
this exact problem of productization
about um how generative AI is used in
Enterprise to support self-service about
data analytics on scale so so take me to
back to I guess November
2022 we have Chad GPT comes out and and
the rest is history but at that moment
you sort of have these two big players
looking at this technology from
different lenses right you have
consumers looking at this and saying wow
wow I can't wait to start using this you
also have Enterprises saying holy crap
what's going to happen but also we can't
wait to start using
this what H where what is the state of
play for Enterprises at that point so
where are they what is their state of
data how prepared are they for what's
coming for generative AI it's it's
amazing question because it was such a
happy moment for me I actually thought
it would come earlier than November 20 2
it's because Genera VI models were um
rapidly evolving since 2017 so 22 was
was a big a big bang for the industry
and to me as a technology person is the
biggest thing about that is it's a First
Technology forever since internet
probably that CEO is coming to data
people and asking for this thingy I want
that tomorrow right so it didn't happen
with cloud or big data or neur Nets
technology people were always selling
technology to to the business site so
this is the first time it actually came
the other way around so see so Chief
marketing officer were coming to to that
data Department saying like I want this
chat agentic analytics whatever have we
have like lots of Buzz wordss around
that I want this experience this Vibe
for me tomorrow right I want to change
so the the the expectation yeah the
expectation was high right and data
people of course the KN for shaking just
you know all of us know how data looks
like in Enterprise and this is why it's
it's manually catered and delivered
within bi tools right so far so the
analytics takes time to create because
data is not in the shape it could be and
then our favorite prospects uh companies
already started to implement like paying
for those tokens right deploying them on
the snowflake red shift getting
hallucinations and I'm like okay so now
come to ILX what ILX does is is actually
a automating context and reasoning for
organizational structure data H and this
is a you know mouseful way to say that
you have your business core data and
your supply chain and your Logistics and
your data L and in your um Erp systems
we can connect to all of them and
basically buil in this semantics and
context for your whole organization
automatically but I believe in human and
the loop I don't believe in Genera which
takes human out of the loop what I'm
saying is we should have this
architectural representation of of
organizational context but we also have
to have workflows for people to
certified certified definition check
conflicts and all of that so we build
this workflows on top of them they're
not mandatory to deploy generative VI
but it opens up the blackbox so it's
kind of changing this Paradigm where
technical people install Technical
Systems or model data for business
people in disconnect in disconnect what
business people actually require it's
it's building this technical part
automatically and bringing business
people in the safer environment
augmented environment to to basically
understand how how the cake is is baked
H business people in augmented
environments what does that
mean which means um think about
marketing right you want to have this
GPT experience for your marketing people
because like friendly speaking like when
when a marketing person comes to me with
this I want this budget for this survey
campaign I'm okay bring me the numbers
where's the numbers where's the data and
then they have to to go to analyst and
and ask for this data so imagine this
word where they can have this chat B
when they ask questions and get answers
so for them to get this uh the setup
usually they would go to data science
department and data science department
in GPT space right it will create
something which is called rug rug is
basically taking off the shelf model and
fine-tuning it on organizational data
let's say from from the hopspot from the
CRM system and all of that so what we do
is actually automating this rug right we
automate the context and reasoning and
then we say oh wow we found this
conflict because this channel
attribution is defined in different ways
in even in the same system so dear
marketer please resolve this ambiguity
before we would like to you know to give
your answer so this is what we we call
augmented which means we Sur as
conflicts of definitions semantics and
data is always conflicted in big enough
organizations and for hallucinations to
not to happen we have to resolve those
ambiguities usually they're even not
picked up by technical people because
they're looking at different parameters
right and this is where we bring
augmentation to business users we say
okay we automate the hard parts of your
organizational data preparation
augmentation context building but then
when semantics is already defined and we
do find those dispares we bring you on
the board to to resolve them okay so
when you actually look at at the
Enterprise environment and and the
current state of play walk me through
from From elex's perspective how how
this would work so obviously you need
access to the organization's information
take me from there yeah so it's crazy
enough but we as s solution and we work
with banks insurance companies Pharma
companies which means uh we do have this
High degrees of of Regulation to to
adhere to we only touch organizational
metadata metadata basically definitions
and usage information to build a
semantic context and reasoning and then
when it's built and the application
layers are built as well when you start
a prompting system we pass this
prompting through the semantic layer
which we automatically create and then
to we create the query to data and the
results are brought back to the user so
the results or data will never touch ilc
systems or leave the cloud s is a
customer premises how does that how does
that work in today's world where you
have your assas Cloud solution but you
get to work with incredibly regulated
data I mean that's like one of the most
difficult parts of uh of of working with
these types of
customers yes so to us being able to
deliver this experience in hours not
weeks is a prerequisite and SAS is the
only model which allows that right on
prise installations uh so much more
cumers are to develop and deliver to
those same Enterprise customers so for
highly regulated Industries what ILX
does is to combine
VI implementation automation mhm data
preparation and governance so governance
is both built in in the data and context
preparation but it also built in in
interactions and we say dear Enterprise
you want to generate AI coupled with
governance we can deliver that and we
can only touch metadata of your
operational systems to deliver that so
it's kind of risk management and total
of ownership Enterprises are looking for
and you know compare it to 80% of tokens
which are spent usually on fine tuning
as customization of a Genera VI models
for your Enterprise data we provide very
cost effective solution as well and
being able to to be up and running in
hours and not months it's something that
also something which is very lucrative
to to our prospects and so so tell me
you know where are we heading you know
from from the space so So today we're
middle of December of 2024 so we were
just about two years into the wave of of
generative AI so maybe even before we
talk about where we're heading where are
we today in the way that you see that
enterprises are adopting generative AI
into their systems mhm so there are two
two kinds of Enterprises those who are
waiting for you know for for everyone
else to to prove it works and Roi is
there and so on so for and the ones
which are running I do believe that the
ones who already running is are going to
be the leaders of you know of the new
markets right and we see that Financial
space Insurance farma very advanced in
Genera VI usage where utility all and
gas TCO to some extent are um lagging
behind to to some extent not so much and
I'm especially passionate about the
acceleration the industry went through
during the last year so
I I do believe that we will have those
three types of of environments for for
Genera VI we will have this ad hoc
prompting environment like this
experience when you have ad hoc
questions you'll have generate VII in
your everyday workflows so for example
in your CRM system in um in your supply
chain so you will be using the same
tools but they're going to be suggestive
and bring insights and interact with you
right and eventually will have also
experience which I called application
free future right so application free
future is you have question or task and
just throw it to Ether or launcher let's
say and then you have to to have this
microservices of different applications
and data microservices to to basically
combine an experience which can provide
you the answer or execute your your
question so this is called application
free future and for that future to
happen we do have to have this agenda
itics workflows everyone speaking about
but not many people know what they are
it's basically ability of different
generative VI agents to collaborate
right so for example you in in doctor's
appointment and this you might want to
to have this re recognition writing
recognition and you might want to have
city scan and all of that are different
agents and you want them to collaborate
to provide you a recommendation maybe so
this is a gentic collaboration that we
do have to have shared context what ILX
brings is this building context and
reasoning for both humans to understand
applications to interact with and
generate to pass through right so right
now it's different Paradigm the Paradigm
is organization is building context for
specific model for specific data set for
specific workflow it's not very scalable
approach it works for now for some of
the scenarists of course it's not
scalable and this is why organizations
actually in majority of the use cases
have small small tackle ins and not
really big road maps about generative Vi
at the moment so you ask me where
Enterprise is heading I believe in 12
months we will see all these systems
which do have this agentic collaboration
and gentic workflows where instead of
having just one narrow task which is
handled by generate TBI you will have
this a application workflow experience
workflow when you have a multiple agents
collaborating and providing you service
and so you see ILX being creating the
context for the communication of these
agents effectively creating a layer of
context on the organizational data right
which is obviously fitting from a
privacy and security and governance
perspective but also is tuned to take
the business information and make it
adaptable and communicative to both the
humans and the Agents alike so that it
can be used precisely yeah capturing the
business acument of specific
organization and the data data
structures underlying and building this
context which is which accessible by all
involved and I also believe that data is
going to be everywhere so right now
organizations are mostly using the
internal data we see industry clouds
popping up especially Health cloud in
Europe for example for insurance
companies to share information I believe
we'll have more and more industry clouds
sharing data between organizations and
we always see companies using weather
apis you know to be embedded in in the
like asthma treatment recommendations so
we have lots of use cases where it's
super cool to use external data as well
so how do you as a startup then go and
work on capturing this business Acumen
because it sounds like a big part of the
work is to actually be able to translate
and and you said before that a lot of it
is about conflict resolution in the
semantics even or the terminology or you
know defining these terms so you know
you need to understand them yourself I I
would assume how does that work from
your perspective El captures two aspects
of of this problem so content and
context content is something which we
call semantics right semantic model can
capture the essence of your data the
essence of existing questions and
organization and context is where we use
graph Technologies like graph neural
Nets which capture the context of of the
data usage of previous activities it's a
little bit like intelligence you know
you understand different former
interactions to predict the new ones and
what we also do we we basically train
those graph models and those semantic
models on domain specific ontologies we
created we captured different knowledge
bases around different industries of
financial services retail iot and so on
we capture terminology workflow
processes metrics analytics and so on WE
captured them in something which we
called business
ontologies big word for knowledge craft
and then we changed a semantic knowledge
cphs sorry and graph models on business
ontologies for specific Industries so
when we come and onboard new customer
via the metadata we say okay so Mr X
your little company but we actually
capture that you have data which is
related to you know to mortar Brien um
you know stores and you do have those
cpg supply chain information and you
have some social aspects in your data as
well because you have social campaign in
your marketing so we capture all of that
automatically and build this
organizational semantics m
I love it youa tell me a little bit
about your own your own Journey Running
Company going from highly technical
leading teams leading groups leading
units that are driving business from a
technology perspective now now in the
role of a
CEO exhilarating I should have done it
sooner yeah you feel that highly
recommended yeah I feel that um we or at
least I'm
um hugely entitled right now to be able
to bring this technology advancement to
masses by building GX so I think it was
so much harder a few years ago to build
a company you know to and so much
Capital required to to build deep Tech
startup nowadays you don't have to have
50 PhD you might have 10 right with all
technology around and still you're able
to deliver the Solutions which are super
helpful to know to end users and improve
their life significantly on a personal
level I'm a married to my sweetheart my
high school sweetheart and I have a kid
and we live on beach of Tel Aviv so it's
kind of it's nice environment to be in
and combining this lifestyle of a of
being entrepreneur and being part of
this community of of um startups in
Israel is just
such a supporting environment so to say
I believe that I'm only able to to build
and scale ILX because I have support of
so many people I love it in have an
amazing journey with elx it sounds like
a sounds like an exhilerating journey
and it sounds like the the the vision
that you have for for bringing
technology to the masses and how to do
that through looking at the
opportunities that generative AI
presents but then seeing the limitations
that that we currently have have and the
way that we've built our data models
until now and the way that we've
structured our the interaction between
the business organization and the
technical data and then bridging those
gaps and and then the observation that
you know we have this short-term road
map that probably every Enterprise has
adopted by now because everybody wants a
piece of the cake but now but you're
actually looking at it long term and
saying okay well this is just the
beginning of something much much bigger
that happening and yeah we can have
these short-term wins but the future is
much broader and much more engaged and
communicative than than we may even
expect and it sounds like you think it's
coming soon it's coming sooner than
later but I would would like to say that
ILX is is a Segway where we meet
customers in different maturity levels
from AI Readiness of the data to
actually establish this augmented
governance to to deploying gen
all of them start from different point
it's important to actually have the
Segway from solution which can cater to
to IMM medial me need of self service
from data analytics and up to generative
deployment and it's part for every
startup I would say right to meet the
customers where they are absolutely
number one rule thank you so much Ina
thank you sure thanks